[MUSIC]
Welcome to the Leadership Society,
Reimagining Work Post COVID.
I'm Brian Lowry and today we're talking
about education, citizens and workers,
education and capitalist democracy.
And I'm really excited to talk
to two distinguished guests,
Rachel Carlson, Co-founder and
CEO of Guild Education.
Rachel is the co-founder and CEO and
their company is on a mission to unlock
opportunity for America's workforce
through education and upskilling.
And I'm also talking to David Osborne.
Dave is author or
co-author of six nonfiction books,
including Reinventing America's Schools,
Creating a 21st Century School System and
Reinventing Government,
a New York Times bestseller in 1992.
So thanks for coming.
Great, so I'm just going to jump right in.
[COUGH] As we think about
reimagining work post COVID,
we have to think about education and
training, right?
So to have a healthy economy,
to have a well functioning society,
we have to train people to
be able to do jobs, and
also to engage in democracy in
a compelling and competent way.
So the question I have for
you two is how do you think about
the function of education in our society?
Where do you place the emphasis?
So David, I'll start with you.
>> Well that's a subject of a lot
of dispute in American society.
People have different views about that,
the way I look at it,
education has two big missions.
One is to help everyone, Develop in
a way that they can live their own
life to the fullest to realize
their fullest potential.
And the other is to help
them develop the skills and
knowledge to be successful
in a modern economy.
I think it's those two things,
there are other things we
need from education as well.
It would be really nice if
the schools were preparing
people to be productive
citizens in a democracy.
They often fail on that score,
as we've seen in recent years,
but I think those are the two
that I emphasize.
>> Rachel, what about you?
Yeah, you know my views on this have
changed quite a bit, I joke that I was
sort of born on third base, I was
grateful to go to Stanford undergrad, but
I'm a legacy and make no illusions
about the fact that I'm clear why I got
the leg up, I stood on shoulders, right?
And so I really thought it was more about,
I'll call it the some of the broader
debates that happen tied
to the educated civic population and
self actualization.
I've actually been able to see a path
through a lot of that debate now,
which is unmatched to
how David described it.
I think if we view education as a bit
more like a Maslow's Hierarchy of needs.
There's a ground floor that
we have to provide to people.
And that ground floor has to start with
the ability to provide for my family or
know that I one day will be
able to provide for my family.
That's so rooted in the American ethos.
And the next level is I want to do
better than my parents did, right?
That's the second part of the American
ethos of how we think about the American
dream and doing better,
and being more capable or
ability to have more flexibility or
the middle class family sustaining wage.
Then above that what happens is people who
after they solve for those two things,
which makes all the sense in the world
from a Maslow's perspective,
will then they want to learn more to think
about how can they be an engaged citizen.
How can they be a contributing
member of their community,
you see people then return to and really
embrace a lifelong learning perspective.
So, that's my worldview today.
>> Got it.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Yeah, that isn't a really compelling
way to put it which makes me think of
something that I'm impressed that you
are willing to say hey, I was a legacy,
I don't have any illusions around that.
I think that's often
an uncomfortable thing to say.
And I wonder what it makes you
think about education as a way to
maintain things as they are, right?
So we typically think about education as a
way to improve the functioning of society.
I wonder as you given that comment,
if you think about how it might
actually maintain things as they are.
>> Man, yeah,
okay we'll go deeper like because I
have a lot of feelings about this.
I obviously I spend my day to day helping
America's frontline workers have access to
education.
So I obviously spend a lot of my time
trying to disrupt the barriers that I'd
argue are heavily oriented around
maintenance, but I think part of
the important thing to acknowledge though
is that nobody's trying to do wrong.
I spent a couple years really deep
in the community college system.
And what I saw there was a community
colleges have an average graduation
rate of 8 to 20% depending on
the school and how you slice the data,
but I never met a bad person
working one of those schools.
I met people who were deeply
dedicated to the mission in the work.
The problem is we built those schools for
a mission in the 50s and
60s which was sending our young
men to school after a war and
creating purpose and meaning for
that crowd tied to an economic need then.
So there's an example and I think we
don't talk enough about that one and
then I'll jump right into the hot bed
that the New York Times would write
a story about everyday if they could,
which is the preservation of
different types of privilege.
What bothered me a lot in my year working
in admissions, and by the way, I'm
proud Stanford alum, I should say that and
I think we need to keep changing, right?
In my year working in Stanford admissions,
it was frustrating to see that there were
some elements of diversity that the school
was able to push boundaries on, and
others which had financial implications
including welcoming and more folks
from the community college system or just
18 year olds from low income backgrounds,
that was a harder choice to make
when you looked at aggregate data.
And so,
I think there is a lot of maintenance,
maintenance of an outdated higher red
system, maintenance of privilege.
And we've got to change that if we
want to have a united citizenship back to
the goal,
if education wants to be productive
towards the ends of united citizenship.
I think the root of our
populism right now is really,
really connected to some of
the flaws of our education system.
>> I liked that you referenced the
creation of the community college system
in part in response to the needs
associated with bringing soldiers
back from the war.
I'd like to think about what the pandemic,
so
these major events in history shift or
can shift how the society functions.
And so as we think about the pandemic,
what have we learned about what we need in
terms of education and training, what is
it revealed maybe that was there that
we weren't paying enough attention to.
And David out, I'll go to you with that.
Yeah, I think it's been
incredibly revealing.
I think a lot of parents in
particular were shocked first by how
rigid their school systems were and
how difficult it was for
them to adjust when the world changed and
suddenly they had to go remote.
And then by the low quality of the
education their children were getting when
they were remote.
The community college system may
have been built for the 1950s and
1960s but the K 12 system was built for
the 1910s and 20s.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It was really built as an industrial
economy emerged.
And it was built on the modern model at
the time, which was called bureaucracy.
These top down hierarchical,
large centralized bureaucracies.
And in the public sector,
they had monopoly status.
They were built to be very stable.
To give you the same thing this year you
got last year and the year before and
the year before that, and
they're very hard to change.
In the 50s and 60s and 70s,
they unionized in most of America and
that made them even more rigid.
And so now I think people have realized,
my goodness,
we need schools that can change and that
can use technology and we don't have them.
We have a system that is
almost incapable of change.
On top of that people realized, our
kids are all different and some of them
thrive in remote online education and
some of them It doesn't work at all.
Some of them need the social
interaction and so
all kinds of families began trying to
create pods and micro schools, crew up and
all kinds of alternatives because
we need choices for different kids.
And when you have a monolithic system that
kind of treats all the kids the same and
batch processes as they might,
they're on an assembly line,
people are finally waking up
to realize that doesn't work.
So I hope it's some kind of turning point.
>> And, if I could add on
that in the Higher Ed Space,
we saw the most fascinating
segmentation of
two things that people had bundled
into one for a long time, right?
What is college?
And what we saw is that people who are
hiring I like to think of the student as
a consumer.
People who are hiring college for a coming
of age experience were devastated right?
There was no social emotional learning,
the dorm experience learning how to
become an adult, all those things
that are really intrinsic for
the 27% of American learners who
ever spend a night in a dorm.
For the other 73% it was so empowering.
Suddenly they didn't have to take the bus
to get to a local campus in order to sit
in front of faculty member who spoke for
an hour and a half and then try and
get their way home or
organize that around their work schedule.
Suddenly there was this blossoming of
what they were hiring college for,
which was skills acquisition.
And so I think that's been something
that's been really fascinating as in
the same way that K 12 is getting
to have a conversation about,
well, what does the student
need from this system?
We're finding that folks over
the age of 22 are saying, wow,
college suddenly started being
more what I wanted college to be.
>> So the barriers that you pointed out I
think in my understanding is that Guild is
in part an attempt to get beyond
some of those barriers for
working age people at ease.
Can you tell us a little bit about
your thinking about that in Guild?
How it works in Guild?
>> Yeah, so our focus demographic or
the 100 million Amercians for
whom we believe in the labor data tells
us they're going to need to rescale or
upskill in the next 10 years.
In order to remain employable and ideally
if we do our jobs have a really good
chance at a stable family
sustaining wage and career.
And so the way we go about that is
aiming to work with about 300 of
the 7,500 schools in the US that
we've found have high quality,
low cost outcomes for working adults.
I wish that number was bigger but
300 is enough and they're growing.
So we work with those schools to help any
employee at companies that we partner
with like AAA or Discover Financial or
Lowe's or Disney, you name it, but
mostly frontline workers across the US to
figure out what are their skills today.
What do they want out of their
career path in the future?
A conversation many have never
had the privilege of having.
Then what skills do they then need
to acquire to get on that path?
And 50% of that time, the answer's
getting into a degree program.
But 50% of the time it's things like
certificates in digital marketing for
people who've been in analog marketing
frontline jobs for a long time or
helping people move from being MA
data entry Associate to actually
becoming a data analyst or actually
the biggest one is people management.
The fastest path to the middle class
right now is teaching someone how
to lead other people.
So a lot of short term kind
of 6 to 12 month programs and
then we just give them a coach and
advisor all the way through.
Which is the recordings that we had coming
out of the community college system was
that the best thing you can do
is pair someone with a coach.
>> Got it.
And so, there seems to be working with
the businesses to make this happen and
one of the things that I'm really
interested in is the respective role of
business and government in providing
things like education, right?
So a big social need.
Should business be such
a big player in this space?
>> I can argue both ways.
So I'll tell you my thoughts.
The fun thing is that Guild was my
graduate school research project.
So I've looked at it from every angle, and
I've sort of maybe annoyed my
investors from time to time for
doing this, but I can criticize it,
[LAUGH] As well as I couldn't support it.
I think that on one angle,
the body was the unit of production for
a really long time.
And that's what got us focused on making
sure that employers were caring for
people's physicality and their bodies.
Now I think that went too far when we said
should employers be the only place where
people get health care, right?
But I do believe employers
should care about their
workers physicality when that
was the unit of production.
Today, the unit of production
is the brain, right?
We're in a knowledge economy.
And so I think it makes a ton of sense for
employers to have a voice in saying here's
what the future of work looks like.
And we have both data self sourced from
university presidents who say they trust
employers more now to say what the future
of work looks like then they can figure
out at their own school.
But more importantly, average American
now would trust their CEO more than their
local college president to tell them
what skills they need 10 years from now.
So that's the role.
That's the role of informing and
giving influence on the learning
which I'm very supportive of.
When it comes to funding, we're
vehemently anti student debt at Guild.
And so the path to avoiding that
has been having employers pay.
I like a world where employers and
the federal government pay.
And I don't think we're paying enough
out of the federal government.
So I think that's where if the world
changes Guild will be very happy to adapt.
>> Great, I don't know Dave if
you have any thoughts about this?
I mean, I know that you think a lot of
schools, I'd love to hear your thoughts.
>> Well, I think the reality is
that business does have a huge
role in education broadly defined.
If you think about the training and
education that people get post college or
post high school if they don't go to
college, who provides most of it?
Businesses to their employees.
And people in government tend to
think about well, we should have this
program and we should have that program,
>> Yeah,
>> There are something like 50 different
programs funded by the federal government,
most of them small but
what they really should be thinking about
is, most of the money is fed by business.
And our role should be to give
people the information they need
about the quality of
different providers so
that they can make better decisions
about buying, training or education.
And then as Rachel said,
providing funds for individuals,
workers and
those who want to be in the workforce, so
that they can access quality training and
education,
because low income people don't
have access to those resources.
So we have to understand that, there's
a market for education and training,
and most of the providers are businesses,
and that's the world we live in.
So let's figure out how to make
it work better for people.
>> I'm really interested in how we
make it work better because Rachel,
you pointed out that healthcare
is tied to employment and
part ways you described it because the
body was the unit of production, right?
And what we really want to go to a world
where we have the same kind of thing for
knowledge, like, I don't know, like,
I'm not sure that that sounds like a
better world than the world we're in now.
So how do you avoid getting
to a place where education is
incredibly tied up in private
industry as opposed to
something that society takes
care of across the lifespan?
>> So I think about it the way
our students talk about it, so
I got to walk into Stanford
with a bunch of AP credits,
because I went to a high school system and
I followed the traditional path.
But our average student is in their 30s,
often a woman, often a mom,
often a woman of color, and
she has often received enormous
amount of training at her company.
And yet our higher Ed system kind of puts
its nose up to that learning that she's
done over often, 10 to 14 years,
whereas I've got high school teachers,
but let's be honest,
did I really have 12 credits of college
learning the day I walked into Stanford?
I don't think so, and but we honor it,
right, so we create systems that honor one
population and it's typically populations
that follow the traditional norm which
then doubles down on privilege and
eliminates access.
So I think what higher Ed needs to do
is open up the doors to honoring more
learning.
The uncomfortable truth in that is that
it's problematic for higher Ed's revenue
model because higher Ed today has very
high cost of acquisition very, very Very
high the top 100 don't put the other
7400 schools in the US pay a tremendous
amount to Google and Facebook and digital
marketing to attract their students.
And then they have to receive enough
revenue on the back end to make that
investment worth it.
So short term programs are very
threatening to universities, but also so
is giving away credits for free now,
again, elite schools can do it but
we've not Said we would honor
the learning that happens on the job.
And I think I think business wants that,
and I think higher Ed is resisting that.
>> Great, so I also want to shift
it a little bit from higher Ed and
think about primary school.
So as I assume many of you listening
know and I'm sure Rachel and
David you know that there
are huge disparities and
outcomes along certainly
among dimensions of race but
class as well in terms of educational
achievement, reading, Math.
And then we also see across all different
demographic groups, as someone pointed
out, a stunning and dismaying consistency
in misinformation in civic education.
Our citizenry just does not understand
how our government functions.
Why is this?
Like what do you think
is causing the failure?
And now David, I'll go to you and I know
you've already talked about how it's
an old system, but the old system was
designed to teach people to read and write
and math and we're failing at that too,
so what do you think is going on here?
>> Yeah,
I think that when we created the system,
which as I said is very stable,
and schools today are not all that
different from they were when I
was going to school 50 years ago.
They assume that students
come to school motivated and
then the teachers will
provide knowledge to them.
And that still works in a lot of middle
and upper middle class communities.
Because many of those students
do come to school motivated and
they managed to get an education,
but In the inner city,
and in some rural areas with
really low income kids,
you can't make that assumption they might
not even come to school speaking English.
They may grow up in a neighborhood where
they don't know anyone except their
teachers who ever went to college and
it's never occurred to them that
they would ever go to college.
And so, what happens is they do okay
through elementary school typically but
then you hit middle school and
you start introducing extra actions and
asking them to learn things like algebra.
And why would you ever learn
algebra unless you saw it as a step
toward college or a step toward a career?
And if they don't see that
the motivation isn't there and
they fall off the conveyor belt and
you see high dropout rates and so on.
We need schools that meet
those kids where they are,
the first job is to create motivation.
It's interesting,
we've created a innovation sector in
public education called charter schools.
And they work, well in some places and
not as well and
others a lot depends on
the state law that governs them.
And a lot depends on whether they're
authorized by a school district or
a state board or a university,
but where they work well,
when you visit one of these schools,
they'll immediately
tell you yeah, on day one,
our job is motivation.
We bring the kids in let's say
we're a high school we bring
them in in ninth grade for
two weeks before school starts.
And it's all focused on building
motivation, building expectations.
Then we tailor to where they are,
we don't just give them the classic ninth
grade curriculum and if they're ready for
it great and then if they're not too bad.
We meet them where they are, we provide
tutors as they need to catch up,
we provide extra time in the summer and
during breaks if they need to catch up.
The word the cliché has
become personalization, but
we really do need to go from batch
processing to personalizing education and
helping each student go from where
they are when they get to school to
where they need to be, and
the old system can't do it.
It's just impossible, it's so
rule driven and so rigid and
so built really for
the convenience of the adults.
Not for the needs of the children that
we need fundamental change in how that
system operates.
And Rachel, I know this is not your space,
but I'm just curious if you have thoughts.
I know you spent a lot of time
thinking about education.
What do you see as a possibility
in terms of improving outcomes?
>> Yeah, I can't profess to be an expert.
I kind of sit on the barbells because
I spend my time in higher Ed and
then we run a preschool daycare at Guild.
So I spend a lot of time thinking about
innovation in childcare, which by the way,
that's another mess for another day.
It's worse than K-12 on a bad day.
But in the K-12 space, I think one
of the things we've lost our way on,
especially amidst the movement to send
everybody to college, which I'm culturally
very supportive of, I think we
have to define what college means.
But I'm culturally supportive of where
that came from and the moving away from
a culture that tracked people based on
race and socio-economic background.
But when we shifted to this world, where
about 10% of Americans went to college to
where that was supposed to be
the aspiration for everyone.
What we forgot to say was, so
how do we want to measure that and
we got really obsessed with basically
the memorization of content.
So much of our K-12 system is around
trying to get you to memorize and
accumulate knowledge.
But we've computers and I'm pretty sure my
kids are going to use a search engine and
a calculator 3x more than I did and
30x more than their grandparents did.
So I'm pretty sure for my kids,
the measurement is going to be do they
love learning and do they love it enough
to constantly contextualize
the knowledge they're learning.
And I don't think any of those tests that
can measure whether they've memorized
anything are really going to matter.
I'd probably fail my seventh grade algebra
quiz if I retook it right now, but
I was able to build on top of that
learning to do the things I do today.
And we kind of have to reset.
I just think we have to reset
the conversation because to do the social
emotional learning, to care for people,
to do what actually I think some of
the system did better believe it or
not in the 20s ,30s and 40s.
Not for everyone by a long stretch.
But what the system did well, for
at least the middle class white male
was not about memorizing content.
It was about providing a platform
to become the type of adult society
wanted you to become.
And so these are all great aspirations but
as as you both know,
better than almost anyone, there are a lot
of barriers to making these changes.
And I'm going to come back to
something you said earlier, David,
that unions you mentioned
as one barrier to change.
And that's actually is a big part
of the conversation we talked about
education teachers unions
are particularly powerful, but
they also are way presumably
to protect labor.
So our teachers aren't paid very well and
last I looked at a 2013 study,
that suggested that Charter schools
teachers are paid less than traditional
public school teachers.
So as you think about,
making these kind of changes.
What do you tell the workforce,
the current teachers, primary,
secondary school, about what they
can expect from these changes?
>> Well, I think that in many ways
the teachers are the most disillusioned
part of this whole picture,
teachers in public school systems.
Gallup does a survey,
has done it millions of times, for
all kinds of businesses and professions.
I think they there are about a dozen
professions they've surveyed
>> And one of the questions it's,
I forget it's 20 questions or
16 questions.
One of the questions is, I feel that my
opinions matter at work most of the time.
And of all those professions education
is the highest and saying no to that.
Public school teachers feel like that
they're at the bottom of the barrel and
outside their school classroom,
they have little authority,
they have no control over sort
of the direction of the school.
And their complaints sort of boil
down to they treat us like children.
We need to make education a professional
and in a profession you have
some role in helping to manage,
helping to run the institution.
The teachers unionized for good reasons
back in the 60s and 70s, it was needed.
Women in particular were
just treated terribly.
Back in the 50s, if you got
pregnant as a teacher you were out.
So, we needed all of those changes.
But now we need to move away from
a model that's built on an industrial
workforce management versus labor
to a more professional model where
the teachers are part of the team that
runs the school and that's a tough shift.
It's happening,
there are all about 150 teacher run
public schools in this country,
about half of them charter, half of them
district, and they're growing slowly.
But all of the status quo, all of
the forces that preserve the status quo
in K-12 education stand in the way of
that and one of them is teachers unions.
They actually don't want teachers
treated like professionals.
They don't want teachers to be able to
move from school to school,
as they choose.
They want districts preserved as they are,
to preserve the protections
that teachers have, for example,
the fact that after the first two or
three years that it's almost
impossible to fire them.
And that's very important
to the teachers unions.
And that creates so
much rigidity in the system and
undermines the ability to make
schools improve year after year.
>> My mom was a school
teacher by the way and
she was quite frustrated because most
primary school teachers are in Cunby.
But I think she also appreciates
the protections, right?
So I think there's a lot of distrust
in the people who are making decisions
about how resources are expended.
And the union is a way to have voice.
It's obviously collective voice.
I wonder how do you change the system such
that you maintain, I hear you saying that
they should be treated like professionals,
they should have a role in running things.
That is not at all I would argue
how it currently functions.
And so if you get rid of unions
prior to making that change,
then you put teachers at risk.
So I just wonder how do you think
about that chicken and egg problem?
>> We need to preserve
certain protections.
So for example,
if you're in a school district,
you should be protected from
the whim of administrator firing.
There should be due process,
there should be a process.
When I was a consultant, our firm
actually was hired to run the Minneapolis
school system to three and
a half years, back in the 1990s.
They actually wanted
to hire our president.
But he wouldn't leave the company he just
founded and so they hired the company.
And one thing that he and his colleagues
managed to do was work with the union in
Minneapolis to develop
a teacher-run system to weeding out
teachers who shouldn't
be in the classroom.
We can do that.
It means modifying the tenure system,
not eliminating it completely.
The same with if we change our
school system so that principals and
their teachers have more power to
actually operate the school and
change the learning model to
meet the needs of the kids
who showed up at that school,
then teachers need more.
Some teachers won't fit this school, or
let's say this school decides to become
a dual language immersion school because
there's a lot of Spanish speaking kids.
And it's far more effective
in that environment.
Well, some teachers won't speak Spanish
and they'll lose their job at that school.
But a district can say you're
not going to lose your job.
We're going to let you choose a place at
a school that will fit you better with
the principal who wants you but
is not a dual language immersion school.
So there are ways we can create more
flexible systems while continuing
some legitimate and very fair and
common sense protections for
teachers and frankly,
teachers welcome that.
They are very frustrated if
you read any of the surveys.
>> Yeah, I think there's not
a lot of disagreement with that.
There's this frustrating being
a teacher these days for sure.
I want to kind of shift back to
thinking on the student side and
later stage in life.
We don't have a lot of,
in this country, vocational training.
And so this is obviously going to be for
you, Rachel.
And by vocational training, I don't
mean what people think of is plumbers or
electricians though,
the kind of basic trades.
But I mean vocational training that
could be even like tech and engineering.
We have a university system and
then people go out,
and often really learn what they
need to do at the job, right?
That is a common, I think, experience.
How do we address the historic inequities
in that kind of training, for you, Rachel?
So I think now people will say,
it's a pipeline issue, but
the reality is when the great jobs were
factory jobs, there was still racial and
gender inequities then too, right?
So it's not as if these inequities are new
because we've now moved to this knowledge
economy.
The inequities that we have now are the
same inequities we had before in terms of
access to the best paying jobs.
And so as you think about what you're
doing the way you're trying to upskill and
prepare people for these array of jobs,
how do you address that historic
inequity that continues?
>> Yeah, so at one level, because
this is a philosophical environment,
I feel like I can go dork on history here.
Part of why America has fewer,
I'll call it technical and vocational,
right, because we called it technical
schools until we started using tech for
another word,
is we've a really heterogeneous economy.
And that's actually great, right?
So when you look at the countries that
have really successful apprenticeship and
technical trainings, whether that's moving
people into what's called the historical
trades, which I'm really passionate about,
or moving people into,
let's call it the 21st
century technical trades.
Companies doing that well have
really homogeneous economies.
So the government and
business tend to align, I'm like, okay,
what are our five things?
There are countries in Europe who are
like, we're a car manufacturing country.
[LAUGH] And others who are like,
we make cheese and chocolate, right?
[LAUGH] That's actually a thing.
America, good,
it's part of why our GDP grows.
We're heterogeneous.
So if you're going to then try and
do something that creates the opportunity,
what we used to do is we did it regionally
and the US had a very regional economy for
horrible reasons, mostly connected
into slavery and then the way we grew.
But now we have a national
heterogeneous economy.
So you have to start there when
you're talking to anyone who lives
anywhere in the US.
They don't want to feel constrained to
what their pathways can be based on their
the region they grew up in or,
to your question, their background.
So then the next question we
often talk a lot about is, okay,
how do we actually do
this in the right order?
And my main thing that I think we need
to do is that we need to actually flip
the order of learning.
Today we say, go get your general studies,
go learn about critical thinking and
all these things.
And then we'll teach you some technical
skills maybe in your senior year, or
better yet [LAUGH] I'll pick
on Stanford for a second here.
We don't have a business degree,
if you want that, you come back for
graduate school, [LAUGH] and
hook line and sinker.
I did it, but that's a problem.
I think we should teach people
the technical skills first,
that allows them to enter the workforce.
And we need to recognize that we're now
in a lifelong learning economy, and
how do we stack the learning on?
And if you change that conversation, you
suddenly open the door to acquiring those
technical skills to people in
a lot more equitable ways.
And so what I say a lot is, why do you
have to go to college to get a job?
Why can't you get a job, learn and then
decide what you want to do in college?
>> All right,
that is a very different system.
[LAUGH]
>> There you go.
[LAUGH] You nodded when I said,
can I go philosophical work-
>> Yeah, of course, no, I love that.
[LAUGH] Go ahead, David.
>> Our government funding
has to shift as well.
>> Yes.
>> We're stuck in this,
exactly what Rachel said,
this mindset that you go to college.
Well, so, even our most progressive
leaders like Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren,
they're all for free college.
But what percent of
Americans go to college?
What percent of Americans stay
in college for four years?
It's a minority.
Most Americans don't.
So you're leaving them out.
You're going to spend all this money
on people who are already a little
bit privileged.
I have proposed, not that anyone's
listening, but we should take that money.
And why don't we say anybody who's making,
has an income today of
less than $80,000 a year,
let's give them an account,
a lifelong learning account.
Let's start with $10,000.
And maybe we'll have a sliding scale and
maybe it'll be at 80,000,
it'll be 5,000 and down when you
make 70,000, it'll be 10,000.
So, it phases out slowly but the point is,
let's give everybody
resources that they can use.
And if they want to use that to
go to community college, great.
If they want to use that to help pay for
a four-year college, great.
But if they're already
in the workforce and
they know they need certain skills,
fine, go at night and
get a certificate or
use the money how you need it to improve
your skills and
your education at your point of life.
And let's make it available for
the bottom half of our income scale,
not the top half.
>> All right, so
you gotta jump on my last question.
So I'll go with Rachael, see if you have
another, something else you want to add.
But this whole series is
about reimagining work.
So, what would you do if you
could reimagine the way education
functions in work?
What would be your primary focus?
What would you like to change?
Yeah, so David hit it but the foreign
40 is dead, right, going to college for
4 years and then going to work for
40 and then retiring, dead.
I think we're entering what I call like
the every four, which is that we're going
to work and every four to five years
we're going to need to pick our heads up.
And either reskill meaning prepare for
our next job or
upskill get better at
today's job that we're in.
And what the data tells us is that white
people who start in their career in
the white collar economy earlier
are going to do more upskilling.
And unfortunately,
people who live in the lower half of the
economy are going to need to reskill more,
which is actually more expensive,
right, learning a whole new job.
And so I would love to see our
funding infrastructure, as well as our
conversation around higher ed, and then
most importantly our higher ed entity.
But in some are already doing this
reorient their business models and
their ways of teaching and their ways of
working to serve the every for economy.
>> Great, and David, you have the last
word what would you want to leave us with?
>> Well, going back to K12 for
a minute, I mean,
your question about what would you change?
I think we need a K12 system in
which we have the people who
run schools actually
are empowered to run schools.
Rather than some central office making
all the hiring and firing decisions and
spending decisions.
And those schools being allowed and
encouraged to diversify their learning
models, particularly in urban areas
where geography is on your side kids
families actually have choices in
terms of the schools they can get to.
So that there are Montessori schools and
there are stem schools and
there are performing arts schools and
there are dual language immersion schools.
And on and on and on and
give the families choices so
that they can find the school
that best fits their child.
And then hold the schools accountable
if the kids are learning and
the parents are happy and
the kids are happy, great.
That school gets to keep going,
might even be invited to create
another school to replicate.
But if the parents are gradually
drifting away, taking their kids out and
the test scores are bad and
the teacher parent surveys.
And student surveys tell you
that it's an unhappy place,
that's school should be replaced by a team
that can do better in that building.
So actual accountability for performance.
I think that's the kind of 21st
century system that works.
And we know it works because we have
it in some places like New Orleans,
which is all charter now, unlike
Washington DC which is half charter now.
And Denver where Rachel is,
which has a lot of charter schools and
a lot of innovation schools
within the district.
Our districts are beginning to
put their toes in that water but
it's awfully slow and we need more of it.
>> All right, great thanks.
Well, I hope we see some of those
changes we are in desperate need
of some improvements that
you both pointed out.
So thank you so much for talking with me.
Next week, we'll discuss the ways
that work controls our lives.
And we'll be joined by Karen Arnold,
Head of Talent Acquisition at Automatic,
a company that has always
been fully remote.
Thank you both again and
that's it for this session.
>> Thank you, Brian.
>> Thanks, Brian.
[MUSIC]